the gyro can experience there's no room
for nuance when you're dealing with
these political battlegrounds when when
you're dealing with right versus left
and one side has clearly established
stance that you're supposed to take
particular gun controls a great example
of that right there's no room for what
about mental health what about the fact
that so many of these people are on
psych medication right what why is that
not being asked are we running one of
the greatest mental health experiments
in history when we're doping everybody
up and SSRIs yeah and you know maybe if
you give 30 million people
SSRIs maybe like twenty nine point nine
million are a lot happier and then you
have a fraction that commits suicide or
detonate yeah you're basically trading
the mean for the variance right you have
blow up risk
yeah there's no room for nuance which is
why I stay out of politics largely do
they drag you in though sometimes I
always try I mean conversation is
conversation you get to get dragged in
sure but I'm sure there's gonna be some
people here's the thing about politics
because there we have a
first-past-the-post system what that
means is that whoever wins 51 percent of
the vote in this country gets a lot of
the power right it's not like
proportional representation where the
greens have 10% and you know the
libertarians or 3% or whatever it's just
like you're all Democrat and power now
all Republican because of that to win
you have to pick one of these two sides
right you have you have to choose you
can't just you can't just make it you
can't just basically say I'm gonna be
you know nuanced about it you can't vote
for a third party that's throwing a rear
vote right I have a friend who's trying
to fix that he's starting this thing
called a good party where like you kick
start your vote so you combine all your
votes you hold them in reserve and then
when you have enough to win then you
vote that person in power right you know
you don't throw away your vote but
outside of those hacks we're never gonna
be a third party elected so because of
that all of your beliefs have to neatly
fit into the Democrat bundle or the
Republican bundle and so when you get
into that tribe if you signal outside of
that roll out out of that bundle you get
attacked yeah so it's literally it's
making you into an unclear thinker it's
making you into a muddled thinker if all
of your beliefs line up into one
political party you're not a clear
thinker if all your beliefs are the same
as your neighbors and your
friends you're not a clear thinker you
literally just your beliefs are
socialized they're taken from other
people so if you want to be a clear
thinker you cannot pay attention to
politics it will destroy your ability to
think
oh but what dread most of modern life
all our diseases are diseases of
abundance not diseases of scarcity right
old times I may have starved I you know
old times if I got sugar that was a
wonderful thing I should have eaten all
the sugar to get my hands on if I got in
a piece of news or gossip that was
interesting data that would have helped
my life and move me forward if I'd
gotten some brief amount of
entertainment whether through video
games or magazines or whatever that
would have been good now it's all
diseases of abundance we are overexposed
to everything so the way to survive in
modern society is to be an ascetic it is
to retreat from society there's too much
society everywhere you go Society and
your phone Society in your pocket
society in your ears you're being
socialized right now by listening to
this podcast we're socializing you we're
programming you everyone's trying to
program everybody the only solution is
turn it off the only solution is to turn
it off and concentrate on your breathing